everything about this trailer has me so
excited because it doesn't look like
cosplay it doesn't look silly it feels
authentic it feels like it's truly
honoring it and the performances by
these the two main leads look awesome
they look absolutely excellent
[Music]
hello there reject Nation we're gonna
watch the trailer for The Last of Us ooh
I'm feeling anxious feeling anxious I
know I'm running late to this I got to
bed obnoxiously late I woke up and I was
like what this trailer came out like two
hours ago and then I just like rushed
over to the to this room to be like I
got we gotta film you gotta film because
uh my brother he got me the jabby clay
he got me the The Last of Us remastered
for PS5 so literally last week I
mentioned this and I I think it was a
Gravity Falls reaction this week I I
replayed it the last of us just about a
week ago and I'm already halfway through
the last of us too because I'm like oh I
gotta play The Last of Us too now yeah
so I'm in a very big Last of Us mood and
now I gotta sustain that feeling until
this show comes out so guys please go
ahead and leave a like that would be
very much appreciated hey let's just see
what's going on in this trailer
[Music]
the roses have faded there's Frost at my
door the birds in the morning and the
watch
the grass in the valley is starting to
die and out in the darkness the Whipper
will scribe wow
starting
Clickers
I got this is such a nipple jump
oh it's crazy
it's your chance
is that test
[Music]
said everything right wow
it just brought this game to life so
much
damn that clicker looked insane
oh please understand glorious
wow what a it's just
really feels like they're capturing the
tone atmosphere the environment of the
game so much and there's something about
you know because like video game body
language movement is very specific and
and there's even something very specific
about the way a Pedro Pascal had that
very last look towards Ellie at the end
that felt like the body language
movement of the video game and and I was
I was walking somewhere the other day
and I was actually thinking to myself
like I wonder if someone would ever if
they play a video game character would
try to like really nail down the actual
body language because it could look a
little goofy but that little Split
Second looked a little bit like how Joel
in the video game himself would actually
move because yeah I really feel like
this trailer strongly captured those
forsaken desolate Vibes just from like
looking at the brief imagery here I mean
it looks like in the trailer you gotta
see tests you gotta see Marlene looks
like you gotta see Bill Tommy I believe
you did see Gabriel Luna at one point
and obviously like Ellie and Joel and it
really looks like you're capturing it
now for for people who haven't played
The Last of Us game uh the the plot is
is pretty simple so it takes place in
like an apocalyptic futuristic landscape
Joel a very disturbed traumatized human
being he's tasked with a mission to
bring uh this little girl to like he's
got to travel across the country and
bring this little girl to this group
called The fireflies because the way the
The Forsaken landscape is now is that
after this virus has spread creating
like variations of zombie-like
characters because you have like people
they call Runners who are just
essentially zombies and then you have
like evolved ones which are clickers
like you saw here which by the way those
clickers look amazing holy crap those
clickers look insanely like accurate and
uh just watching the body language of it
and then bringing that sound design
alive is is so great would you end up
discovering and this is early on in the
plot so it's not like a major spoiler is
that Ellie was bitten by uh one of the
infected she does not evolve or change
and that she actually is immune so what
they're hoping for was to take her to
the fireflies the fireflies they take
her to the fireflies that they will be
able to perhaps produce some type of
vaccine or find the answers to a cure to
the virus they're gonna go into some
little spoilers here even though it
happens at the beginning of the game if
you haven't played it some little
spoilers and this is what I really feel
like Pedro Pascal strongly bringing a
life right now and you did see imagery
of it would look like from the actual
was presumably the first episode in the
prologue and what makes Pedro Pascal's
character Joel so Disturbed is that at
the very beginning of the game when the
infection the virus first starts
breaking out he has a daughter named
Sarah Sarah is killed by one of the
military members as they're trying to
escape town for survival so this is like
I believe
there's a big time Jump Man I mean even
though we just played last week it was
like 10 to 20 years later after Sarah is
is killed so a lot of it is Joel just
seems so Disturbed and has a difficult
time allowing himself to be vulnerable
not only has he changed so much via the
landscape of the Apocalypse he is also
now tasked with saving this and
protecting this little girl and bringing
across country so a big part of the
emotional journey is him like he's still
grieving and he can't let this girl in
who also doesn't have a family doesn't
have connection she's always felt
abandoned by everyone else like Ellie is
probably hands down my favorite video
game character of all time like without
spoiling the video game experience or
when you essentially play as three
different characters over the course of
the last of us one and last of us too
playing as Ellie is is my personal
favorite you know so a big part of the
journey with Joel and Ellie is you know
Joel learning to become close again with
someone one else and then also you know
having the the Sarah surrogate
experience and and feeling like he can
make up for it like there's a lot you
can read into with the emotional context
of it and then of course you know Ellie
having an established family member as
well and being able to bring out the
heart within Joel so a big part of it is
Joel learning to break down those walls
once again like he's a hardened texting
me he doesn't like fully break it down
but you know he does he's become a
softer gent it's a beautiful story it's
a beautiful game and and it's so it's so
heartbreaking and dark as hell but so
gripping and I really feel like what
this show is bringing to life is that
emotion is that mood because you have
that very dour harsh experience uh
throughout this whole game and it is a
journey like you go through seasons and
and they're going through the seasons
here and the production design and the
way they're bringing it to life looks
just so excellent like everything about
this trailer has me so excited because
it doesn't look like cosplay it doesn't
look silly it feels authentic it feels
like it's truly honoring it and the
performances by these the two main leads
look awesome they look absolutely
excellent so yeah I'm thrilled for this
show man I I feel like it's actually
going to be something really special and
Pedro Pascal he can really pull it off
and also oh my God what is her name the
one who played Leon Mormont uh uh
whoever's playing Ellie forgot her name
so sorry feel bad something Ramsay she
looks like she's capturing Ellie
perfectly as well big part of the show
is going to be really focused on their
chemistry their connection and I already
feel it I'm already getting all the
feels in this one trailer alone so yeah
guys like this looks excellent thank you
so much for being here let's uh let's
talk soon
good